we begin the day as joe biden prepares
to mark one year in the white house
the leader of the world's sole
superpower is trying to hold together a
world that's about to lose its balance
of power
if you're thinking of threats from a
rising china or a nuclear iran
don't forget a resurrecting russia too
moscow is making demands on washington
and nato to pull back and to stay back
no more eastward expansion no nato
membership for ukraine a return to
soviet-like satellites orbiting the
russian mothership
high-level talks last week between the
u.s and russia nato and russia and the
osce in russia ended with no progress
instead the osce's head warned the
threat of war in europe's backyard is
dangerous and real german foreign
minister analina bearbach's visit to
kiev today sent a message to moscow we
will not act as if the berlin wall never
fell
fears of a russian invasion of ukraine
have jangled nerves in the region
after visiting a memorial to
anti-government protesters who died in
2014 and elena bearbach says any
solution to the conflict must come
through dialogue not arms
meeting ukraine's foreign minister
dimitro culeba bierbach offered an
explicit gesture of support for ukraine
solidarity
solidarity
european solidarity for the sovereignty
and territorial integrity of ukraine
that is not up for debate not for us and
not for me personally any further
aggression would have a high price
we've emphasized that today once again
russia is building up its troops on the
ukrainian border
both the european union and the us have
threatened to impose further harsh
sanctions if russia goes ahead with an
invasion
for years ukraine has called on germany
to deliver arms to help boost its
abilities to defend itself kuleba says
russia doesn't share ukraine's
cooperative attitude towards diffusing
the tensions
we have a very constructive stance on
this matter
but unfortunately
our constructiveness isn't mutual on
russia's part
from kiev bierbach goes to moscow on
tuesday where she'll meet russian
foreign minister sergey lavrov
she's keen to revive four-way peace
talks in the normandy format which
includes germany france ukraine and
russia
well my first guest tonight is constanza
steltzen mueller she's an international
relations analyst and she holds the
fritz stand chair at the brookings
institution she joins us tonight from
washington constance it's good to have
you
on the day
i want to begin by
asking you as someone who comes from
germany who experienced those winds of
change back in 1989
is vladimir putin is he asking europe
and the world with his demands to act as
if the berlin wall never fell
hi brent and thanks for having me on um
thanks for reminding me of my age as
well but no you're quite right um
the
i i think that
to anybody who read the two draft
agreements that the kremlin put in front
of the white house and nato
uh just before christmas had to conclude
that what the kremlin is pursuing here
what vladimir putin is pursuing here is
no longer just
neutrality or finlandization for ukraine
but something much much larger and it is
really the rolling back of the
democratic transformation
of the former countries of the warsaw
pact that are many of whom are now
members of the eu and nato
that's a really big deal
it is a big deal and when you consider
what is at stake
is germany
is europe's voice
are they as loud as they should be in
these discussions i mean i i'm wondering
are washington and moscow talking over
berlin and brussels
yeah there's two parts to this question
here uh the question is are the
americans trying to listen to us and do
we have anything to say
on the former point i can tell you and
you probably have seen it yourself uh
the white house about a week ago
published a list of their phone calls
and meetings with
senior politicians across europe and i
think it had about 100 entries
so i think that question is fairly
summarily answered
um
the unfortunate
answer to your second question is that
it seems to me that the signaling coming
from berlin and then from europe overall
um is pretty confusing
so in berlin you have uh annalina
baybach who's as you said heading to
moscow tonight for meetings tomorrow
um who has said very clearly as far as
i'm concerned nordstrom 2 the pipeline
is on the table
last week several senior social
democrats coalition partners um the
party of olaf schwarz the chancellor
disagreed in public
and the defense minister did so on the
day
that the buy administration was trying
to defeat a
senate vote tabled by senator cruz to
sanction the pipeline in other words the
mind administration has been bending
over backwards and we haven't exactly
been um
shall we say first coming
and at the same time you have christian
democrat politicians as well saying oh
you know we shouldn't we shouldn't have
economic sanctions like um taking russia
out of the payment system swift it's
confusing
well how do you explain germany's
reluctance
to say we're going to kill nordstream 2
because it would obviously it would hurt
vladimir putin it would hit him where it
hurts but they've been reluctant i mean
this is something angela merkel didn't
want to do and now we've got olaf
schultz basically you know carrying on
that that miracle legacy
well um let me walk you back on that um
the chancellor merkel and and u.s
president biden in the summer
came to an agreement
on um bilateral
cooperation on ukraine
which said very clearly that um
energy security and and pipelines uh
would be on the table if
uh russia committed any act of
aggression against ukraine
that was read um as including nordstrom
2
and
also i think more importantly
politically it kind of meant that you
know whatever happens to ukraine germany
in europe now owns that problem
um
schultz has been
quite ambiguous about his commitment
on this point
um the most generous interpretation i
can think of
is that he and his allies in the
government want to preserve strategic
ambiguity about consequences that
wouldn't per se be a mistake but i do
think given the truly astounding
language that's coming out of the
kremlin these days basically saying you
know we're not going to negotiate these
agreements with you you can sign them
that's you know that's it and we're not
going to talk arms control or trust
building measures with you
or foreign minister sergey lavrov whom
bairbuck will meet tomorrow saying
um
you know after 1991
these countries the former countries of
the warsaw pact were orphaned
territories these are countries that are
now members of most of them members of
the eu and nato
um and i think when you have the
rhetoric ratcheting up like this and an
arms build up like you have on ukraine's
eastern border i think it's time for
europeans and specifically the germans
who play a central role here to be more
articulate in their language with the
the german foreign minister i know she
wants to revive the old normandy peace
uh format
which
you know obviously has france and
germany as mediators between moscow and
kiev
do you think it's is it too late for
that
i think i do i think uh i think that
this is
really buying time and i think everybody
in berlin knows that i think the foreign
minister knows that that's again i think
not illegitimate
but i think that is what we're doing
here um the question really is does
anybody have a way
to um
sort of get the kremlin down from the
extremely high flagpole on which it has
uh positioned itself
that's really hard to see again given
the military buildup that's already
there
recent increases in recent days
um and the really astonishingly
uncompromising belligerent rhetoric
um it's hard to see how the kremlin does
that without losing face and we know
that's not something it likes to do
and what about the options for the west
moving forward if going to war over
ukraine
is out of the question
should the u.s
nato should they arm ukraine heavily
enough
so that it can at least make
another russian incursion at least
uncomfortable and ugly for the kremlin
well i mean the us and the uk have been
doing that
already
and i think the ukrainians on that point
are fairly relaxed i mean there are some
things that they haven't received such
as i don't know patriot missile defenses
um
or manpad stingers but at least that's
what i'm reading
um
but
i think the ukrainians are relatively
well equipped and trained to fend off
anything sort of short of a massive
full-scale invasion it's still not clear
that that's what the russians
are um
gearing up for
um
i think the more important
thing to understand here is that for
anybody who has like me since you did
mention my age lived through the
yugoslav wars of uh the 1990s when i was
a reporter for insight the weekly paper
that was a decade-long war
and a slow unraveling
of the yugoslav federal republic
into
military mayhem war crimes and genocide
and the the risk that i'm seeing
is that you could see a protracted
extended conflict with sort of unclear
um battle lines um
atrocities being committed
um
culpability perhaps on both sides you
never know in combat
and then you have
you have a humanitarian disaster you
have refugee flows
you have
thousands tens of thousands of
frightened people fleeing and needing
help
and then i think there comes a moral and
perhaps a legal debate in the west about
helping
civilian societies on the battlefield
and whether those might need and the
helpers and and the and the and the
people being under attack
um need some sort of military protection
and i think
the professionals
know exactly that that is a possibility
but that is a moral and legal and
political morass that nobody i think
really at this point wants to discuss
publicly let me get one more question in
before we run out of time i just want to
broaden this out before we say goodbye
the us is preoccupied with russia and
ukraine efforts to revive the iran
nuclear deal as well
china has to be watching this and taking
notes
uh i'm wondering is this going to have
any bearing for the future of taiwan
well clearly
the kremlin and the and and beijing are
looking at this and trying to figure out
how resolute
um
the
the by administration is
how
durable and sustainable alliance
cohesion is and whether there are chinks
in in the carapace of the alliance
within europe or within european
capitals
and of course in this context the sort
of messaging confusion and reluctance
that i was talking about earlier in the
context of the berlin debate
is unhelpful because of the key role
that berlin has to play in mustering
european cohesion
and so and
not just because of the pipeline
and and so
that is i think unfortunate not just
because it could be seen as some
commentators have suggested as
encouraging or even enabling the kremlin
but also sending signals farther abroad
and
that might be something which we would
regret greatly at a later point say if
if there is a chinese move against
taiwan
let's not forget that apart from being
an asian democracy taiwan is also one of
the world's largest producers of
semi-conductors that's right and sits on
a very important sea lane
unfortunately consensus we're out of
time
i wish we had more time constantly still
the timeless
constances it's good having you on the
show please come back again i'm sure
there's going to be plenty to to talk
about between you and me us old-timers
thank you
absolutely